die Bundeswehr steht personell wie
materiell nach wie vor an den Grenzen
ihrer Leistungsfähigkeit aber man kann
Panzer hatten dann fährt man im VW Bulli
ins Gelände und übt das Aussteigen ist
der Ausfall der Pumas bei der jüngsten
Übung ein herber Rückschlag für uns wir
haben hier seit Jahren den
mangelverwaltet was gelegentlich wie
eine Lachnummer wirkt es den Wahrheit
eine sicherheitspolitische Tragödie ist
die Bundeswehr noch zu retten und wenn
ja zu welchem Preis herzlich willkommen
zu einer weiteren Ausgabe von Kontext
fragen wir mal ganz konkret es will ja
keiner hoffen und es steht aktuell
natürlich auch nicht zu Debatte das
tatsächlich die Bundeswehr dieses Land
Deutschland verteidigen muss wäre sie
dazu in der Lage aktuell nein seit
Jahren gibt der Staat weniger Geld für
die eigene Verteidigung aus als der NATO
gegenüber versprochen wurde das war
wahrlich einmal anders im Kalten Krieg
war die Bundeswehr eine der stärksten
Armeen im Bündnis die Bundeswehr Löwe
ein modernes her beim Schaf Schießen von
hier und Luftwaffe zeigt die Bundeswehr
ihr modernes Gesicht dieser Kampfpanzer
Leopard gehörte den modernsten Panzern
der Welt kurze Einschub genau diese
ausgemusterten Panzer vom Typ Leopard 1
wurden gerade für den Export an die
Ukraine freigegeben der Kalte Krieg
wurde früh zum Geburtshelfer der
Bundeswehr die Bundeswehr ist in
befriedigender Weise geeignet
gemeinsam mit unseren Bündnispartnern
jenen abschreckungsauftrag zu erfüllen
der zur Wahrung des Gleichgewichtes
notwendig ist mit Ende des Kalten Kriegs
fiel auch das Feindbild Weg Abrüstung
und Schließungen von Kasernen Volken
2014 aber wird klar die Friedenszeiten
sind vorbei alte Feindbilder tauchen
wieder auf mit dem Einmarsch Russlands
in der Krim und dem weiteren Handeln
nach wie vor in der Ostukraine haben wir
eine neue Zeitenwende im selben Jahr
schreiben die NATO-Mitglieder ihr schon
2002 beschlossenes Ziel erneut fest 2%
des
Bruttoinlandsprodukt sollen in die
Verteidigungsausgaben fließen erreicht
hat das Deutschland aber noch nie
man hat bestimmte Absichten gehabt seit
2014 man hat diese Absichten nicht
erfüllt zwar haben sich seit 2014 die
Verteidigungsausgaben erhöht um aber die
ausrüstungs Misere zu beheben reichte
das nicht aus ist Krieg in Europa und
wir sind nicht in der Lage ein wirklich
angemessenen Beitrag zur Landes- und
bündnisverteilung der NATO zu leisten
keine der drei Divisionen und keine der
insgesamt acht Brigaden ist aus dem
Stand als Großverband für die Landes-
und bündnisverteidigung einsetzbar ein
katastrophales Bild diese Beiträge
zeigen aktuell kann die Bundeswehr ihren
wichtigsten Auftrag nicht erfüllt
doch welche Probleme stecken dahinter
drei große Schwachstellen hat die
Bundeswehr erstens die schlechte
Ausstattung angefangen bei der
persönlichen Ausrüstung den fehlenden
Jacken und Unterwäsche Nachtsichtgeräte
zum Beispiel sind Mangelware in der
Bundeswehr und ganz dringend ersetzt
werden müssen die alten Funkgeräte es
reicht zum Üben sage ich mal ein
weiteres Problem die Standardwaffe der
Bundeswehr das G36 der Firma Heckler und
Koch wenn es draußen sehr warm ist und
bei heiß geschossener Waffe trifft das
Sturmgewehr nicht genau dass das G36 in
der heutigen Konstruktion keine Zukunft
in der Bundeswehr hat dass wir jetzt mit
Hochdruck an einem Ersatz Arbeiten für
die Soldaten und Soldaten das war
2015 und heute ist klar die ersten
Waffen des Nachfolgemodells wird die
Truppe erst ab 2024 in der Hand halten 9
Jahre nachdem sie mit Hochdruck
angekündigt
und das Gewehr ist nur ein kleiner Teil
auf einer langen Liste an
ausrüstungsmenge hinzu kommen die
Lieferungen aus dem eigenen Bestand an
die Ukraine das hat die Lage bei der
Bundeswehr weiter verschlechtert die
Einsatzbereitschaft von Großgeräten
betrage teils nur knapp 50%. von mehr
als 30 Transportflugzeugen A400M waren
zuletzt nur 12 einsatzfähig das
Großgerät der Bundeswehr ist eine
Ansammlung von beschaffungsmiseren seit
1972 seit 50 Jahren fliegt zum Transport
der Truppe die CH 53 ein Hubschrauber
der inzwischen mehr Wartungs als
Flugstunden hat er gilt als modernste
Schützenpanzer der Welt nun aber schlägt
ein generalarm bei einer Übung mit 18
Pumas sollen alle 18 Pumas ausgefallen
sein nicht eine Heeres Brigade ist
derzeit voll ausgerüstet einsatzbereit
eine Dokumentation zur
Einsatzbereitschaft der Bundeswehr aus
2016 finden Sie in der Mediathek
das zweite große Problem der Bundeswehr
existiert ebenfalls schon viele Jahre
hier brauchen wir mehr Personal mehr
qualifiziertes Personal nachdem die Zahl
der
Grundwehrdienstleistenden bereits ab
2002 reduziert wurde brachte das Ende
der Wehrpflicht im Jahr 2011 eine
drastische Verkleinerung des Heeres mit
sich eine Sparmaßnahme und von daher
führt aller Wahrscheinlichkeit nach an
einer erheblichen Personalreduzierung
kein Weg vorbei als aus der pflichtarmee
eine freiwilligen Armee wird muss die
Bundeswehr sich aktiv um Personal
bemühen die Zukunft von der Bundeswehr
hängt davon ab dass wir das geeignete
Personal finden und deshalb ist die
Attraktivität des Berufes so sehr
wichtig mein Ziel ist es dass die
Bundeswehr zu einem der attraktivsten
Arbeitgeber in Deutschland wird auch
sechs Jahre später war dieses Ziel nicht
erreicht im Gegenteil Ende 2020 Beklagte
die Bundeswehr über 20.000 unbesetzte
Stellen in den höheren Laufbahnen
konkret fast jeder fünfte Posten bei der
Luftwaffe fehlen sogar die Hälfte der
Piloten ein zusätzlichen Schwachpunkt
beim Thema Personal zeigte der
Totalausfall bei der pumaübung auf
einige Schäden aber sind wohl schlicht
auf Bedienfehler oder mangelnder
Ausbildung zurückzuführen die dritte
Schwachstelle hat die anderen lange
überschattet ständige Rücktritte unter
fairen des politischen spitzenpersonals
im Verteidigungsministerium einmal Male
Mazedonien und zurück bitte und zwar zum
Nulltarif also das hat den fast ja nun
tatsächlich den Boden aus meinen
zumindest die empirten Kollegen Rudolf
sehr freundschaftlichen Gespräch die
Frau Bundeskanzlerin informiert dass ich
mich von meinem politischen Ämtern
zurückziehen werde
und um eine Entlassung gebeten
es ist der Tag an dem der Misere zum
ersten Mal Lüge vorgeworfen wird
Rücktrittsforderungen nun jeden Tag es
könnte ungemütlich werden für die
bundesverteidigungsministerin Ursula von
der Leyen muss aufklären warum ihr
Ministerium in den Jahren 2015 und 16
über 200 Millionen Euro an externe
Berater gezahlt hat die Ministerin gilt
schon lange als angeschlagen 5000 Helme
für die Ukraine Flüge mit so einem
Hubschrauber zuletzt ein misslungenes
Video aus der Silvesternacht so richtig
wohl gefühlt hat sich Christine
Lambrecht in ihrem Amt wohl nie der
Rücktritt von Christine Lambrecht machte
einmal mehr deutlich das ist der
Bundeswehr an führungs Kontinuitäten
fehlt im Verteidigungsministerium soll
es nun Boris Pistorius richten ich will
die Bundeswehr stark machen zumindest
bis zur nächsten Wahl der 24 Februar
2022 markiert eine Zeitenwende in dieser
Rede verkündete Olaf Scholz vor einem
Jahr den größten sonder Etat in der
Geschichte der Bundeswehr wir brauchen
Flugzeuge die Fliegen Schiffe die in See
stechen
und Soldaten Soldaten die für ihre
Einsätze optimal ausgerüstet sind
100 Milliarden Euro sollen die
ausrüstungslücke schließen bisher hat
die Regierung aus diesem Sondertopf aber
nur ein Bruchteil ausgegeben
Rüstungsausgaben von fast 13 Milliarden
Euro aus dem Sondervermögen bewilligte
Haushaltsausschuss heute allein zehn
Milliarden kosten die knapp drei Dutzend
Kampfjets F35 der US-Filme Lockheed
Marken auch 120.000 neue Sturmgewehre
bekommt die Bundeswehr und 20.000
Digitalfunkgeräte Gewehre Funkgeräte und
Kampfjets die 2027 einsatzbereit sein
werden viele meinen zu wenig zu spät wir
sind zu wenig Energie zu wenig Reformen
und deswegen glaube ich sind wir gerade
dabei die zeitenwände mit Karacho gegen
die Wand zu fahren es gibt Gefahren
dafür dass eben dieses
zeitenwendeprojekt zu scheitern droht
wenn jetzt nicht nochmals reinkommt wenn
wir nur mehr Geld geben wird die
Bundeswehr nicht effektiver werden
sondern das ganze System muss im Prinzip
umgestaltet werden zum System gehört
auch das Bürokratiemonster
Verteidigungsministerium mitsamt seiner
beschaffungsbehörde bevor die Bundeswehr
neue Gerätschaften bestellen kann
erfolgt einen komplexes Vergabeverfahren
wir müssen weg von Goldrand Lösungen in
jedem Fall und wir können jetzt auch
beim schnellen Herstellen der
Einsatzbereitschaft jetzt nicht
europäische Vergabeverfahren durchziehen
die jahrelang dauern das geht nicht
solche Flugzeuge die kauft man eben
nicht im Baumarkt um die Ecke sondern
das dauert dann seine Zeit Frau
Lambrecht meint hier Jahre ein weiterer
Zeitfaktor nach der Lieferung muss das
Personal erst am neuen Gerät ausgebildet
werden auch wenn die
Verteidigungsausgaben im Jahr 2022 einen
Rekordwert erreichten genügt der
Sondervermögen laut Expertinnen und
Experten nicht um die Lücke in der
Ausstattung zu schließen laut dem
Deutschen Bundeswehrverband ist es
Sondervermögen bis 2027 aufgebraucht und
laut werbeauftragter fehlen statt 100
eher rund 300 Milliarden Euro die
Bundeswehr ist nach wie vor im freien
Fall deswegen erwarte ich schon morgen
ein Umsteuern von der Politik wenn dann
nachher für die Fähigkeiten der
Bundeswehr was gutes bei rauskommt freue
ich mich
momentan ist es ja noch nicht wirklich
umgesetzt deswegen bin ich da noch ein
bisschen vorsichtig selbst den Bündnis
kann die Bundeswehr ihre internationalen
Verpflichtungen ein Jahr nach der
scholzischen Ankündigung nur schwer
erfüllen auch wird es zwei Prozent Ziel
der NATO im Jahr 2023 erneut verfehlt um
es zu erreichen wäre nicht nur ein
einmaliges Sondervermögen sondern eine
dauerhafte und langfristige Erhöhung des
verteidigungsetats möglich was denken
sie sollte der Verteidigungsetat
langfristig erhöht werden schreiben Sie
es mir in die Kommentare wenn Sie mehr
zum Zustand der Bundeswehr wissen wollen
schauen Sie gerne den Beitrag des ZDF
Morgenmagazin und zu einer weiteren
Folge Kontext geht es hier und für ein
Abo wäre ihnen auch dankbar